huit années et autant de finales de ski
nautique de vitesse dans l'espoir de
dominer ses 1800 mètres de crosse et
ainsi remporter la médaille d'or
européenne
laurent pradal vient enfin de la
décrocher pour lui c'est aussi son
trophée de la persévérance ça prouve que
malgré malgré que l'on prenait l'argent
à tout âge un peu si on à la fois de
réaliser des choses un peu l'heure on
peut y arriver
la famille du skieur de 43 ans le
soutient depuis ses débuts pour elle
c'est une récompense durement mérité ce
qu'on le voit tous les jours de l'année
faites travailler pour cette course et
là elle est championne d'europe donc que
du bonheur il méritait de gagner parce
qu'il s'engage corps et âme dans sa
passion dont le soutien tout au long de
l'année
là aujourd'hui on était très heureuse
pour lui et pour tout l'équipage aussi
des neuf sportifs
laurent pradal était le seul français de
la compétition en catégorie f3 et pour
cause c'est l'unique licenciés de ski
nautique de vitesse son club espère donc
que sa victoire suscitera des vocations
des gens vis des ambitions pour le ski
de vitesse et que beck que tout jeune
skieur et envies de s'accomplir comme
laurent vient de le faire
laurent prada elle se lance un nouveau
challenge l'an prochain décrocher une
autre médaille d'or en catégorie masters
cette fois ci